hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and
in this video i wanted to basically just
answer
your property investment questions so
anything you've got around property
whether it be around mortgages
tax deal sourcing rent to rent hmos
anything at all
comment your question below in the
comments and i'm going to do my very
best
to answer your property investment
questions i've been investing in
property now
for 12 years i've done over 300 deals
and
now it's your turn to pick my brain so
get commenting below and i'll do my best
to answer
now right now i'm going to answer the
questions from last week and i'm going
to answer your questions below in my
next
q a sunday video next week so before
before you comment now do me a massive
favor
and hit the like button also if you're
not subscribed
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification bell on so you don't miss
my answer to your question so do that
right now
okay let's see what we got from last
week i got so many questions so bertie
evans
says do you predominantly invest in
property but also in stocks
etc or just property just curious
so i pretty much just invest in property
and business
i have got a little bit of money in a
few other things
i don't really talk about it because i
don't feel like i'm in a position to
advocate it because i don't know enough
about
it whereas property i know really
really really well uh so the vast
majority of my wealth
is in property and um not the thing is
though
people think samuel you should diversify
but i do have diversified just in
property
i've got get very very a very vast
property portfolio
i've got properties that i control i've
got commercial
properties i've got residential i'm
developing i'm so i feel like
even if the economy changes quite a lot
my property portfolio is
so diverse and ultimately here's why i
love property so much because
everybody's always got to live somewhere
i mean
it's it's an asset that's not only going
to give you rent
but it's also stood the test of time so
cash in the bank we all know cash in the
bank is a bad idea
because as as things go up as inflation
happens
the money loses its value so that's why
people say oh why don't we invest in
gold or silver or
or property because property is bricks
and mortar
and it stood the test of time everyone
needs somewhere to live
we've got a shortage of houses and
overpopulation of people so it's a
really good place to have your money
from a long-term
capital appreciation perspective but
also
property is going to give you an income
because it's an asset that's a
it's a producing asset i like producing
asset and this is just me i mean
the reason i invest what i invested is
because i study people like warren
buffett
warren buffett who's one of the richest
men alive
says that he likes assets that are
producing assets
so like bitcoin for example don't get me
wrong bitcoin's doing really really
really well
but it doesn't give you any rent it
doesn't produce anything
you just have to just hope that it just
goes up and then when it goes up what
are you gonna do you're gonna sell
you're gonna keep it i uh financial
freedom can only come
from an asset that's producing revenue
so yeah i love property i know it i live
it i breathe it
and that is where the vast majority of
my money is held
all right and that's just my opinion
that's just what i choose to do and i
have them for very long time
sergio says love what you do question
how do
i need to structure my least option to
benefit from capital depreciation from
day one in england
um okay so you want to benefit from day
one capitals appreciate if you want to
benefit from day one
then you need to just fix the price
below market value
so a lease option agreement is when you
secure a property and you have the
option to buy
it down the line so let's say the
property is worth 250
000 pounds if you secure it now
for 220 000 pounds with the option to
buy in three years time
then you've immediately benefited from
from equity in the property
um if cabba's appreciation though that's
where property just
appreciates over time you can't predict
that
you can try you can buy in an area where
properties have bombed out
and you suspect it's about to bounce
back but
capital appreciation is something that
is not a given
you know you can predict and you can try
if you're doing a lease option agreement
i'd
still make sure that you're getting cash
flow from it every property you buy
every asset that you own in my opinion
has to be giving you
money every month it's not giving if
it's not producing anything
and it's not an asset it's just
something that you own and you hope is
going to go up in value
but something that you hope will go up
in value doesn't pay the bills
you know you need the bills paid and i
know that there's often all these buzz
words and excitement
and trends and but but what i'm what i'm
saying
is what served me for the last 12 years
what's enabled me to become financially
free
and it's in my opinion very solid solid
guidance
um okay next tom goodall
what made you make the complete career
change from being a magician
to a multi-million pound property
developer
um so i didn't i didn't really go from a
magician to a multi-million pound
property developer i went from
um working for my dad who had a
children's entertainment agency and i
was
i was i guess technically a magician for
a few months when i was 16
but i didn't go from that to them being
a multi-million property developer i
went from that
to then quitting and crossing my fingers
and hoping that
i would be able to make a living in
property
um what made me do that was that i
didn't want to work for my dad anymore
my dad was
you know my dad my dad means that i've
got a very very good relationship
to this day but working for him at that
time
was just not really great the pay wasn't
amazing
and i just felt controlled i felt like a
prisoner
in in in the company and three months
after starting working for my dad when i
was 16 i was just like man this is
this is i don't i can't see this until
i'm 67.
you know i'm really i don't feel
fulfilled
i read rich dad poor dad and um
you know i came to the conclusion that
actually i needed to get some passive
income
and i started going to some property
networking events and i thought wow
property sounds great
and then just decided like a lot of you
a lot of people that watch me they're 17
years old they get inspired i think
i went full time in property which was
risky
i was living at home with my mom and
you know i just thought my overheads
aren't too high um
i started working i'm managing
properties
i got my first property at the age of
17. i was like yes
then all the rules changed with the with
the big recession and the crash
and i had to adapt and i i went through
the
recession and got through it i was just
starting out so i didn't have anything
to lose
as i got through it that's in fact most
people you'll find they actually
make money in recessions in crashes
it's a good time to get into business
during a crash everything is the
opposite of what you would think
so that you know that's how it's died
and then i just organically
grew my my property company into a
multi-million pounds
company but that didn't that didn't come
easy it came with a lot of work and many
many years and a lot of failures
um but i am where i am right now
so i hope that helps all right dureo
says samuel thanks for the upload what
do you think about investing
in the world cheshire while still living
in london
i don't think it's necessarily a bad
idea in fact
i think it's better for you to invest in
cheshire
right now than london and if i
if i was living in london i'm living
just outside london
london has gone up in value a lot and
it's dropping right now and
not only that but the return on
investment in london is very very
poor generally speaking so investing far
away from home is something that a lot
of people don't want to do because they
say
i need to be close by because if there's
a problem i need to step in
but the thing is if if that's your plan
a if your plan a
is if there's a problem i need to step
in there will be a problem
and then you'll have to step in it's not
financial freedom it's it's
you being a slave to your business and
the whole way that i've structured my
business
is that it's passive so the properties
might not be near my house it doesn't
matter why because i've got management
companies in place
so you've got to you've got to follow
the money and you've got to invest in
areas that's going to give you a good
return on investment
and systemize it well that's that's
that's my advice
okay is a mortgage
to live in a good idea is a mortgage to
live in a good idea
it's not a good or a bad idea it's
probably
better than buying a house to live in
cash
having a mortgage but a mortgage on your
house where you live in
is is still technically bad debt because
good debt and bad debt okay good debt is
when you take out a loan
but that loan that you've got is
actually producing you money
and people people get mixed up with this
they think debt is bad
or they think debt is good and and that
the truth is there's good debt and
there's bad debt and good debt is very
good and bad debt is very bad
if you borrow money to live in a house
that house that you live in
isn't paying you any money
because you're living there you're not
renting it out you might go oh yeah but
tell me it's going up in value yeah
you don't know that again that's that's
a chance it might go up if it might go
down
capital appreciation doesn't pay the
bills it's not giving you any money
because you're living in it and if you
rented it out chances are it probably
wouldn't give you any money anyway
because it's not the right type of house
to work as a buy-to-let
so getting a mortgage to live in a house
my favorite option is renting i rent
where i live
i rent where i live and i rent out what
i own
and i think that's the smartest thing to
do but i think i would rather
have a mortgage on a house that i live
in then have to save up and buy
cash because then i got so much money
tied up
in a house that's not producing me any
money
that's not good all right last question
i hope you enjoyed the video if you are
smash the like button as well don't
forget to subscribe last question
jbh says how would a 17 year old do
deals such as rent to rent and rent to
service accommodation
would they need to do in someone else's
name so
jbh if you are 17 and you're going to
rent to rents and stuff
the the hardest part of doing deals is
finding the deals
that's the hardest part if you can find
the deals
i mean rent to rent deals you probably
need to put a couple thousand pounds
into a rent to rent deal
and then if and then and then the work
involved with the rent to rent
it could make 500 pounds a thousand
pounds a month
if you can find that deal and you can
put the work in and produce the profits
but you're you're not 18 so you're
struggling with the paperwork side of
things or whatever
just get someone in on the deal bring in
a guarantor to back you
and even put down the 2 000 pound that's
needed up front hey will you sponsor me
and back me
i'll find the deal i'll manage it you
put the money in
you put it in your name and we'll go 50
50 on the profits
and i'll prove myself on this first deal
and i'll get experience and i'll get
money
and i'll get testimonials and i'll build
assets
and i'm not talking about assets in
terms of physical property assets
i'm talking about assets in terms of
your brand and your story now
a testimonial is an asset it's just a
different kind of asset
so you want to be building those kind of
assets as a 17 year old and experience
and then when you're 18 you go right now
i'm going to do another one but i don't
need
i don't need a guarantor right now i'm
going to use the money that i made from
the first deal
just get started just do something too
many people think too many people make
excuses
two people say i'm only 17. i'm too
young or i'm too old
i ain't got the energy i'm in a job i
can't do it look what did i say
right the start of this video what did i
say i said that
i was 17 when i started same age as you
and i said
but thank god i was living with my mom
so my overheads were low what did i do
right there
i flipped the cards i took something
that some people would say is a negative
and i flipped the cards and i turned
into a positive i said i'm 17
which is great because thank god
i'm living at home my overheads are low
so i can afford to quit my job and go
full time into it
what did i say i said i got in during a
recession i said but hey
i had nothing to lose that's how i got
rich
and i see too many people too many kids
i'm sorry to have rant and have a go but
i see too many kids
coming to me 17 18 i can shout at a 17
year old
because i was 17 when i got started you
know what they say they're like i'm only
17. i haven't got the money i haven't
got the credit
i haven't got the this i'm thinking shut
up full
you're 17 which means you've got no
overheads
risks doesn't even exist in your world
there's nothing
you've got everything going for you oh
and if you're too old i'll say the same
thing to you with more respect but i'll
say
you've got more experience you've got
this this you've got to take the cards
that you've got and you've been dealt
with
and you've got to flip it for your
advantage and don't focus on what you
don't have
you need to focus on what you do have
that's the biggest thing i can say to
you guys anyway
any questions you got comment below i
want to see you win
that's why i'm getting passionate now i
want to see you win if you want to join
me by the way the property investors
crash course 12-hour program with me
12-hour program where we work on your
plan and we make sure that you become
um you become skilled
by the end of the day to find good deals
it's a freak program it's on me it's on
the house
comment below your questions join me
at the property investors crash course
i'll leave a link in the description
i'll see you there peace out thank you
so much for watching
[Music]